[Music]
1674 pretty pretty high rated opponent
here
all right let's go e4
e4 e5 and let's see how the okay so
never mind there's not not going to be
four knights there's going to be a
philadel
what do we do in this position
there's two good moves and oftentimes
they transpose into each other so the
way to quote-unquote punish the philidor
of course this is not a reputation but
this is the way to get an advantage is
to strike in the center with d4
knight takes d4 and we have
better control of the center grade
position
and okay so there's multiple setups here
that are considered quite good
one is to put the bishop on f4 and then
play queen d2 but there's a setup that
kind of flies under the radar
which i think is extremely nasty for
black and that is to
thank you about that is to fianchetto
the bishop g3
g3 bishop g2
and the idea is basically that the
bishop collaborates with the pawn and
makes it very difficult for black to
free himself in the center with d5
so i i like the end getting my bishop in
the filter okay c5 so classic
classic move
uh but i think
it's a mistake
why is it a mistake no it's a positional
positional error
it creates a backward pawn on d6 that
pawn was already kind of weak now it's
backward
and correspondingly it creates a very
weak square on d2 not on d5 now with
that in mind where should we put the
knight this is a pretty important
decision
we shouldn't just throw it on a random
square
we should try to make the knight work
for us
as efficiently as we can so knight f5
allows bishop takes f5 i'm not sure this
trade is in our benefit
i like 92 because from here the knight
can go to f4 and obviously
control the d5 square i think this is a
better square than b3
now do we need to rush with knight f4 is
this something we need to do right this
moment no
first
it makes sense to complete our
development let's castle
and it would also make sense to play h3
okay bishop g4
so
we're not too worried about bishop takes
c2 that's not that scary
um
if we were worried about it we could
play f3 here but i don't particularly
want to play f3
let's play h3 to chase the bishop away
if bishop takes c2 happens what should
we take with
interesting question because both pieces
can recapture
but there is one recapture that i like a
little bit more than the other
let's see what people come up with here
and these are already like high level
positional decisions that you know as a
1700 you should start learning how to
make
yeah i like the idea of taking with the
knight if we take with the queen you're
kind of walking into knight d4 with
tempo it's not the end of the world but
it's also a little bit unpleasant and
we're still not allowing d5 here we've
got three defenders on that square and
only two attackers queen b6
so
a really good setup here is not only to
reroute the knight to f4 as some people
are indicating
but also to limit the to restrict the
knight on c6 as much as possible how do
we restrict that knight a concept i've
talked about on many occasions this
particular pawn arrangement
we play the move c3 right now the pawn
is controlling the knights to advance
advancing squares
95 this is kind of aimless
now we could go f4 but then that would
deprive the knight of that square i
think f4 is too hasty
um
now we want to develop our bishop it
would be nice to develop our bishop
let's say to e3 or even to g5
but we can't do that because we dropped
the b2 pawn
okay so you might be thinking about b3
but we all we can actually make a move
that
prepares to connect the rooks and it
also defends the b2 pawn so it kind of
kills two birds with one stone it's it's
a harmonious move and that's queen c2
and it prepares a couple of different
things it prepares the move rook d1
which reinforces our control over the d5
square and rook on d1 is better than a
queen on d1 and it gets the queen out of
the way and of course it frees up the
bishop
okay knight c4
pointless i mean black is preventing us
from getting our bishop but we can play
b3 whenever we want to chase the knight
away
um
but we don't have to rush and this is
something i want to emphasize we don't
have to rush with b3 how can we improve
our position instead let's practice not
rushing
attempting move how can we improve our
position i've already mentioned this
move
swag fun thank you
okay so knight f4 is one idea
but let's try to play as flexibly as
possible let's let's start with rook d1
and you can see that this knight is not
causing us any damage right we can play
b3 at any moment
all right i think that was a good time
to play before i just wanted to
emphasize that there was no rush but now
that i've emphasized let's go b3
i'm i'm tired of this knight let's get
it out of there
now we continue our development now
where should we put our bishop well
you could put it on g5 and trade for the
knight on f6 and try to get your knight
to d5 that's one approach
but giving black the dark squared bishop
here i think is a little bit
imprudent because we'd be left with a
not a great light squirt bishop i don't
see a need to give away our bishop let's
just go bishop e3 let's develop it too
a nice square word x-rays the queen
okay queen c6
and now i think it's it's a good
opportunity we have a good opportunity
to reinforce our control over the d5
square what am i talking about how do
what does that mean
reinforce our control over the d5 square
so knight f4 yes is a possibility
but but i'm also thinking of the move
pawn c4 using our pawns to clamp down
even further on that square and now the
knight has an even nicer path through c3
it doesn't interfere with the f pawn in
case we want to play f4
right so this is a little bit more
harmonious now i know you're looking at
this probably saying aren't we afraid of
weakening the the d4 square and the
answer is no because we have a bishop
that guards and we have a rook that
guards it
okay knight b4 i'm going to speed up a
little bit here we're just going to move
our queen can move it to b2 we can move
it to e2 it doesn't really matter
doesn't really matter
let's move it to e2
and now let's focus on
continuing to improve our position
putting more pressure in the center what
plan what very typical plan allows us to
increase the pressure turn up the
pressure dial in the center what am i
thinking about
g4 g5 yeah g4 g5 is interesting but
you know let's let's be a little bit
more russian school of chess about this
yeah doubling rooks let's go rook d2
rook d1
i'm not committing to anything yet i'm
playing as flexibly as possible i
haven't really pushed any of my pawns
yet
okay black is doing the same
i don't care about this knight can
remain there for all at once it's not
worrying at all
now if
he
doubles
his rooks
okay that's not a great move
yeah resigns okay i don't know what
where that came from
but this is what happens when you put a
lot of pressure on somebody right people
people kind of buckle under the pressure
yeah that is a weird of a strange one i
guess
he thought that i moved the rook away
from a1 so a2 is hanging now but it's
not
very strange strange move
um
not much to say about this game i mean
this was a pretty classic philidor so we
played g3
you guys can check this on your own but
i know that d5 is a move here and i'm
not sure what the evaluation is i know
d5 e5 knight g4 is a line
i think white's supposed to be better
here but this needs to be checked if you
want to play g3
but most people don't know about this so
they end up castling and c5 is already a
mistake
i would say a lot of people under 2000
tend to play c5 in such positions and
this is the same exact
let's call it the same syndrome
that causes people to play c5
in this position a lot of people play c5
here
and i still think fundamentally it's
it's connected to this urge to attack
something right you're pushing a pod and
you're creating a threat
and it's just people not realizing that
creating a threat is not an inherently
good thing right it has nothing to do
with in order to judge a move it's not
enough to say that it creates a threat
it can be a good thing
but it can also be an incredibly harmful
thing
that makes sense they want the presence
in the center but this move is an
illusion it doesn't actually control the
center it actually weakens the center
so
be very careful about and the only
reason you would play c5 is if you could
follow up with d5 and break through in
the center
i mean this just
creates a massive hole on d5
now we did a couple of things so we took
with a knight
in order not to allow this move with
tempo and this centralizes the knight so
why is this also a good move because it
centralized the knight
and also i was already gearing up to
play c3 and restricting the knight okay
so queen c2 freeing up the bishop
activating the rook chasing them chasing
away the knight developing the bishop
reinforcing the pressure on the d5
square
same ditto for knight c3 getting the
queen out of the attack and then
doubling rooks i mean really all we did
was very natural play
um
rook bd8 we had a nice idea here i
wanted to show
i was excited to play this during the
game unfortunately it was ruined
uh can anybody tell me that we have a
nice little maneuver here and you can
find this by identifying you know the
white piece that's not really doing
anything and trying to find a home for
it this is a classic idea
so it's too early for e5 e5 e5 the rook
has enough defenders
yeah h4 bishop h3 so we go h4 and then
we reroute the bishop to h3 kicking away
the rook
and and then e5 becomes a problem
so for example after bishop h3 or c7 now
e5
is a big issue because black can't take
so and knight b5 is coming and this is
already very very nasty
the one maneuver like this can really
can really make a difference
and in general this is something to
remember this idea of pushing out the
h-bond and going bishop h3 or bishop h6
i guess we're just gonna use my desktop
mic sorry uh this
hopefully the audio quality is okay so
anyways all i was gonna say is this idea
of playing h4 bishop h3 is actually
very strong in a lot of positions um
i wanted to give an example
of one of my games where i applied the
same concept but in a very different
in you know instantiation
so here's an example of where i did
something similar this is one of my
games 2019 and and i'm playing black
here all right so it's black to move
here and basically i'm going to walk you
through quickly through the essence of
the position there's a lack of
equivalence here black has this d4
square which is really really weak but
if you compare it to the d5 squirrel the
d5 square is not weak at all right the
d5 square is easily guarded by the c6
pawn so
ideally i came up with a plan here of
trying to get a knight to d4 but there
is
a lot of problems associated with that
plan why there's three pieces that are
all
guarding the d4 square so it seems
pretty unrealistic but it actually is
realistic and you want to go piece by
piece so
we have the move rook 88 in our pocket
to
you know cancel out white's rook
white's knight can be canceled out by
playing c5 at some point but what about
white's bishop can you find a plan
that allows you to trade white's bishop
this is where this concept comes in
yeah very good you guys are getting it
immediately i played h5 king h7 bishop
h6 i was like using the king for stuff
make the king work a little bit
and then once this happens white is left
to the bat bishop
and then i go c5 and knight d4
so this works you know like clock when
the king is safe it can always drop back
to g7
so that's the bottom line you know this
idea of getting the bishop to h3 or h6
can be quite
quite nice um and that's that's all i
wanted to say i mean obviously once
people ended the night it was over
i would do more but it's i want to get
some sleep enjoy gary stream guys thanks
for hanging out and that's all i have to
say thank you folks thanks for
watching me practice i'm will do my best
tomorrow
[Music]